there's a lot of different concepts by
the way many people call you a
conspiracy theorist but i think you're
very comfortable with that and nowadays
anybody that says there was more than a
single you know
shoot you know just one person involved
you're a single bullet theory
you're a conspiracy theorist but i'm
going to go through some of these and
you tell me which one of these you give
some credence to
and which one of them you say pat i
don't know if i give a lot of credence
to this
so the grassy knoll you know saying the
fact that
you know the the the second shooter uh
that came you know uh
the the you know what is it called um
there was another person it wasn't just
somebody that came there was somebody
from the other side that shot as well so
that one you just said right now there
was a second shooter
right so that one is yes you're saying
that when it happened you already said
it
that that is what i believe and i won't
repeat what i have already said
sure all kinds of shown that was the
position of
the other shooter yep the second one is
the black umbrella man you know steve
louis with who
you know he lifted it up and was he
signaling
did he have a bullet that he shot out of
the umbrella maybe he had something that
he did or he was signaling to another
shooter and then they do the interview
with them afterwards and he says no i
just held the umbrella up because
i'm a conservative republican and i kind
of wanted to distract him and kind of
wanted to
go back and you know highlight and link
it between him and chamberlain because
of the appeasement et cetera et cetera
so do you do you give any credence to
the black umbrella man
i am um i'm not certain about that
it would be an incredibly fortuitous
uh unbelievably synchronized event
if it just happened in that kind of a
fashion at the same time of course
it could have happened in that way i
don't know the black umbrella man
has been looked into and i don't have a
simple straightforward
unequivocal answer to give you i just
wonder if sometimes somebody shows up
and says
i just want you and i was involved and i
wanted to tell you this please keep this
between
like i get regular emails because i'll
interview somebody that's controversial
let's just say you know resemble garvano
okay and then people who are in the mob
will email me and they'll say
please keep this anonymous you will not
know my name but dot
dot dot here's what really happened in
the events with paul castellano and john
gotti i was there
at sparks restaurant et cetera saying
they give me their whole story i wonder
if you got a lot of these emails over
the years here's the third one
mob did it because the mob helped
the kennedys with illinois because he
kind of needed it so they got the mayor
i don't know 7 000 dead people voted and
then
they were hoping that the kennedys were
going to help with castro and
cuba because uh mayor lansky was taking
a hit with his hotels in cuba when fidel
came and says you got to get the hell
out of here
and then rfk flips and rfk ends up going
after the family
after the mob and so rfk ended up
feeling guilty the fact that maybe he
was the reason i killed his bob do you
think
uh killed his brother do you think the
mob had a major involvement in the hit
i think the mob had a major involvement
subsequently
to take care of various people beginning
with lee harvey oswald
and jake and jack rubenstein um
jack ruby little jacob rubenstein from
mafia from the age of 17
in chicago i do not believe that the
mafia played
a role in the primary decision to
assassinate the president
because remember what they would be left
with would be robert kennedy as attorney
general
uh so where were they going with that i
do believe there's no question
that they were used to follow up to get
rid of various people
after this happened yes got it so they
were not the lead
domino but they were one of the dominoes
needed they were not the first one that
pushed everything we could not have
dared to do it and
more importantly patrick they did not
have the wherewithal
uh to really undertake this without
and to get away with it uh only only
the highest level of government and that
cia military
level could have uh performed this and
gotten away with it
so so so the then the next one becomes
the government did it the government was
behind it according to biographer philip
shenan he said apparently bobby
kennedy's first suspicion was that it
was some rogue element in the cia
however after meeting with the cia
director john mccone
rfk changed his mind however at the same
time cia leaders were notably angry
with kennedy over the bay of pigs
invasion you mean you we all know this
and the cia spokesperson edward prince
told the nbc while the cia conspiracy
theories make good
fodder for movies but they are pure
fiction thoughts on that
i believe when i say cia i'm a cia
related
whether they were actively involved at
that time whether they recently resigned
remember john allen dulles
was the cia director he was fired by
kennedy following the iron yeah he was
fired
and then he is appointed to the warren
commission and he's the one
who played the major role in the warren
commission justice warren was pretty
busy with the supreme court
the two u.s senators and the two
congresswomen are pretty damn busy
with their congressional duties so who
is running the show there
um alan dulles incredible unbelievable
if you wrote this
if you read this in a novel you wouldn't
believe it yeah
very interesting people were on that by
the way you know the president of the
world bank what is he doing i know
obviously gerald ford but
why why is the president of the world
bank
on the warren commission to what does
that have to do with
very interesting people that were
involved in that and you know the
uh the the the southerners on there
senator uh russell um
and senator long they richard russell jr
they very reluctantly went along at
lbj's insistence and we all know you
know best of all there in texas
what lbj can do with the literal
figurative twisting of the arms not many
people
dare defy lbj so if you like this sort
of shortcut from an interview i did
click over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye
[Music]